alors docteur laurent alexandre vous
vous dites qu'il faut pas faire
confiance aux professeurs à vous à non
pas du tout moi je suis un fan un
admirateur de raul c'est ce que vous
disiez vous êtes un fail vous étiez
enfin je suis un fan de rock juste
terriblement déçu par les deux études
qu'il vient de sortir
bon nous ce que vous allez dire à partir
des études qu'il a sorti on ne peut pas
dire que la chloroquine marche
hélas je voudrais comme tout le monde
qu'il vient traitement
je suis désolé qu'il n'y a pas de
traitement parce que moi aussi je vois
des gens mourir
le drame c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas la preuve que la chloroquine
marche on ne sait pas si la chloroquine
est positive on ne sait pas si elle n'a
pas d'effet on ne sait pas si elle n'est
pas négative mais comme votre heure le
faisait remarquer avec le shin gougnard
la chloroquine marche très bien en
éprouvette recul des russes mais chez
les malades
elle aggrave les malades qui ont du
chikungunya donc avec la chloroquine il
faut qu'on ait des essais cliniques qui
permet d'être certain que ça marche chez
les malades et pas seulement
d'éprouvettes parce qu'on ne soigne pas
les éprouvettes
on soigne les malins juste laurent
laurent alexandre moi je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable et je vais vous dire
ce que pensent les téléspectateurs mois
et voilà il ya plein de gens qui
réagissent 1 sur les réseaux sociaux et
qui disent notamment
oui mais alors puisqu'on n'a pas de
traitement si une personne est condamnée
mine de rien est autant tenter quelque
chose forcément puisque son cas va pas
s'aggraver une fois qu'elle sera décédé
donc mais aux personnes tentées la
chloroquine mais personne personne n'a
dit qu'il fallait pas donner de
chloroquine en attendant les résultats
de l'étude discovery moi personnellement
je suis favorable à ce qu'on donne de la
chloroquine sous contrôle médical et
croix et pas du tout en automédication
en attendant d'avoir les résultats de
l'étude sur 3200 malade qui va permettre
de trancher définitivement sur
l'efficacité de la chloroquine chez les
malades
il ne s'agit pas du tout de ne pas
donner d'espoir aux malades et de les
laisser condamner mais il faut dans
cette affaire-là retrouver un peu de
raison permettez moi de te parler
moi je parle nation je suppose que ces
lois et je vis de bruxelles
à bruxelles il ya un gouvernement
d'union nationale aucun malade ne
réclame de rock rockin les malades font
confiance au gouvernement
ils font confiance aux médecins et on
n'est pas dans l'état d'esprit actuel il
faut reconnaître que tout le monde s'est
trompé et votre
votre collègue le disais tout à l'heure
tout le monde sait mais raul tôt si
souvenez-vous que raul qui il ya
quelques semaines expliqué que le
coronavirus c'était moins de morts que
la cantine est que les morts à protein
est donc non médecins nous spécialistes
nous sommes tous trompés
donc il faut maintenant pour fassent
preuve d'humilité il faut pas qu'on
donne de faux espoirs
un tout le monde s'est vautré dans cette
affaire-là vous avez vu que des gens qui
étaient très sûrs d'eux comme trump et
johnson ont complètement changé en
angleterre aux etats-unis de stratégie
et à new york y ait un véritable carnage
donc la communauté médicale la
communauté scientifique les politiques
ont mal appréhendé cette affaire du
cours vinko renard virus maintenant il
faut que nous soyons extrêmement
rigoureux pour l'empereur d'une maladie
infectieuse il faut beaucoup de temps et
le professeur peron qui est un grand
spécialiste de la maladie de lyme avec
nous pour dire à quel point dans la
maladie de lyme
on a mis des années et on n'a toujours
pas de consensus et le point sur peron
s'est battue pendant des années pour
qu'on reconnaisse les formes chroniques
de la manie de lyme hélas dans le cas du
coroner virus il il est à craindre qu'on
hépatites suite un vaccin et qu'on n'est
pas tout de suite des traitements
donc il va falloir attendre il va
falloir réussir le confinement et il est
peu probable qu'on ait une solution
magique
contrairement à ce qu'espère l'opinion
et qu'on est un médicament miracle dans
les semaines qui viennent
j'ai peur qu'il faille des mois et des
mois d'essais cliniques pour accrocher
progressivement la vérité scientifique
donc il faut calmer le jeu il faut que
les français deviennent aussi zen que
les belges et il faut arrêter cette
guerre quand tu iras où il était pro
raul c'est pas le sujet raout le sujet
c'est la vérité scientifique et de
soigner nos malades le plus vite
possible alors il ya un ami voilà qui
s'appelle ram dit voilà qui me dit il et
victimes de l'ostracisme des mandarins
des hôpitaux parisiens
karim zéribi karim toit est pour toi est
ce qu'il faut faire confiance au
doctorat ou alors est comme moi voilà tu
es pas tes papilles pas médecin tu tu
vois la mémé tu as tu un avis et tu
t'écoutes un peu ce qu'on dit toi comme
ça a priori
est ce que tu lui très confiant est-ce
que tu comprends que ce qu'on vient de
dire quand on dit voilà il est victime
de l'ostracisme de
voilà des mandarins des hôpitaux
parisiens et comme je disais tout à
l'heure aussi un petit peu victime un
petit peu de la communication et de son
look manger un avis de citoyen
évidemment pas de médecin ou le
d'experts mais en qualité de citoyen je
dirais que notre pays le spécialiste des
polémiques inutiles et stériles qui
aujourd'hui peut prétendre qu'il faille
opposé les essais cliniques sur la
clotilde et l'a dit trop missiles à à ce
que propose eric raoult terre et 46,1
des plus grandes virologue de france et
c'est une sommité internationale à plus
de 2000 publication a été et le
reportage daddy reconnu par ses pairs à
plusieurs reprises on n'a pas affaire à
un farfelu mais c'est ce que j'allais
leur élection de l'été fan de lui
ces princes est pas un charlot sorti de
nulle part de que quand eric raoult est
dit les choses
prenons-les ce qu'il dit dans sont dans
sa totalité
il dit des choses intéressantes il dit
il ne faut pas s'automédicamenter il dit
il ya un danger à prendre des
médicaments sans prescription donc déjà
îlots mais l'idée qu'il faille faire
n'importe quoi
ensuite il dit donc il faut aujourd'hui
prendre le mal à la racine faire baisser
la charge virale donc prescrire le
traitement des parcs
que dit le gouvernement on le prescrit
en réanimation en fin de parcours
là où irritable là où raul dit un peu
d'effets à un moment donné on a affaire
un des plus grandes du roller de france
est une sommité internationale
c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut écouter
pourquoi aller lui chercher des poux
parce que il a effectivement un look
atypique une personnalité forte des
négos non s'en fout de ça aujourd'hui il
s'agit de sauver des vies c'est le
combat pour la vie que notre pays et la
planète mènent aux outils nous explique
ait des gens qui sortent guéri moi j'ai
des amis de marseille cyril qui sont
allés alliés chu de kiel me dis qu'est
ce qu'ils me disent ils me disent on
nous fait faire des tests pour savoir
s'ils sont porteurs du virus est
derrière nous avons des
électrocardiogrammes dans des prises de
sang mais c'est sérieux ce que ces
raouts c'est pas c'est pas un pantin
respect pour ce monsieur tangente par
cohn-bendit lui dire qu'il faut fermer
sa gueule mais on marche sur la tête
mais cohn-bendit qui sait et a fait pas
dans sa vie eric en route
raul qui l'a dit déroule-t-il à il a
sauvé dès qu'il a sauvé des vies
il ay l'at il a fait des recherches qui
sont aujourd'hui reconnus à l'échelle
internationale un peu de respect
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que on a
perdu confiance dans le pays au départ
on nous disait une grippette
et après on s'est rendu compte que c'est
beaucoup plus que ça à fond nous disait
ça touche que les personnes âgées
vulnérables comme des pathologies on se
rend compte que finalement ça peut
toucher des gens de 45 ans et puis on a
eu cette gamine dramatique de 16 ans est
morte et au midi
ben oui aujourd'hui ça peut toucher tout
le monde donc bien sûr qu'il faut
respecter confinement gestes-barrières
mais faisons confiance aussi à nos
scientifiques la planète entière orenga
draw tallec respect et nous on ne
dénigre dans notre pays il c'est pas
possible il faut qu'on arrête ce sport
national qui consiste à vouloir tirer
sur ceux qui sont debout et il avait la
tête haute
il n'a pas dit qu'il fallait pas faire
d'essais cliniques il a pas il a dit il
ya urgence
le président de la république nous dit
c'est la guerre là c'est la guerre il
faut utiliser toutes les armes pour
sauver des vies aujourd'hui et des gens
qui ont utilisé ce procédé et qui sont
sauvés alors après en multi dit aussi
c'est pas miraculeux on va pas sauver
tout le monde ils disent ça peut
effectivement baisser la charge virale
peut être utile en début de traitement
voilà j'ai du respect pour cet homme
j'ai envie de l'entendre et c'est un
gourou c'est un virologue qui a fait ses
preuves
il faut le prendre comme tel et encore
une fois on pose la pratique sur un
homme alors que notre combat à tous
d'accord ou pas avec lui c'est le combat
pour la vie donc mettons nous d'accord
poursuivant des essais cliniques telles
que ont envie de faire les institutions
regardons ce qui se fait à
l'international avec le procès des
routes elle regarde ce qu'ils sont aussi
ali a chu marseille méditerranée à ce
que raout encore une fois c'est
quelqu'un de respectable le reconnus sur
la scène internationale sont une pierre
un moment de qualité de français peut
même dire aux logs de cette dimension là